the nbc procedural law and order special
victims unit has captivated television
audiences with hard-hitting stories of
murder and sexual assault ripped from
the headlines with that many
installments in the can there are sure
to be some interesting facts about the
massively popular show's history cast
and crew these are their stories
back in 1999 dick wolf creator of the
original law and order initially planned
for his new series to be called law and
order sex crimes i don't like the sound
of that
and neither did the production studio
had at the time who didn't want sex in
the title so wolfe went with the actual
nypd sex crimes units official name
special victims unit honoring the real
life officers who investigate sexually
based offenses in all of new york city's
five boroughs
rapper and actor ice t has played
detective finn tutuola for more than 16
seasons becoming a fan favorite for his
portrayal of the street smart
no-nonsense detective
first spit that lollipop out before i
smack it out your mouth but finn's
long-term presence on the show almost
never happened the rapper only agreed to
four episodes at first because he was
concerned about the brutal shooting
schedule saying in his memoir i'd rather
have less money and more freedom but
ice-t signed on for the long haul after
he was reassured that as part of an
ensemble cast the hours wouldn't be
grueling and the residuals he'd earn as
a series regular on a potentially
long-running show would earn him a
steady post-show income just like to
quote ice a little money machine
the addition of actor richard belzer as
detective john munch made svu the only
prime time television drama ever to
technically be spun off from two
separate shows the munch character was
previously in homicide life on the
street and also had a four episode run
on the original law and order munch has
appeared in 10 different television
programs across five different networks
including appearances in the wire
arrested development and even the
x-files
why is a detective from another network
tracking down extraterrestrials on fox
what i'm looking at here is an fbi agent
like to talk about space sailing
shortly after being cast in the series
as olivia benson in 1999 actress
marishka hargitay actually became a
trained rape victim advocate she made
the decision after her fan mail switched
from autograph requests to real-life
victims sharing their stories with the
woman behind the fictional detective you
survive the abuse dia
you're going to survive the recovery her
dedication to victims of sexual assault
didn't stop there hargitay established
the non-profit joyful heart foundation
in 2004 the charity provides support to
survivors of sexual assault domestic
violence and child abuse the foundation
even brought experts in the field
together with the writers and producers
of svu to help craft storylines for the
show a ripped from the headlines 2016
svu episode about a presidential
candidate accused of sexual misconduct
was set to air on october 12th i'm a
handsome charming millionaire women
throw themselves at me but the episode
was ripped from the schedule and
postponed for undisclosed reasons and
may never air at all some speculate it
may be shelved permanently because a few
days prior to the episode's original air
date the infamous bombshell access
hollywood tape featuring then
presidential candidate donald trump was
leaked to the press meanwhile ice-t says
the lost episode wasn't one of the
show's best and he thinks they got rid
of it because it was too on the nose but
he also adds they paid me for it i don't
give a [ __ ] really i got my money
for the first 11 seasons of svu the vast
majority of episode titles were just one
word long but beginning in season 13
keen-eyed viewers began to notice a
pattern
[Music]
place work starting in the 13th season
episode titles were all two words always
with the same number of letters as the
number of the current season so
acceptable loss from season 14 is 14
letters long and manhattan transfer from
season 17 is 17 letters long and so
forth that's pretty cool right
[Music]
look at me i just know stuff
but when season 18 premiered in late
2016 the titles stopped following a
specific pattern or did they
tell me we have a lead stone cold no now
that we're up to season 23 eagle-eyed
viewers will notice that the episode
titles so far have been 23 letters long
so the svu pattern continues
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too
[Music]